Speaker 1: Ted Cruz has gone viral. And it's
not good. I don't know that Ted Cruz has ever
gone viral for something good. I remember
when Ted Cruz sort of humiliated himself
by apparently accidentally liking porn
on Twitter, and then they blamed it on
a staffer or something like that. And then Ted
Cruz went viral when Trump called his wife ugly.
And Ted Cruz went viral when he left Texas
during the power outages and went to Cancun.
If Ted Cruz has gone viral, it's usually
not good. And Ted Cruz has now gone viral
for sort of his version of what we called the sir
routine. So let me let me explain that to you.
Ted Cruz yesterday had a meeting with the D.C.
trucker convoy. People now. There's there's
so many things going on here. The D.C. trucker
convoy is the American version of the Canadian
trucker convoy who drove around burning gas and
diesel and honking their horns in a principled
and defiant protest against mandates. Now you
might be saying, David, what mandates are there?
Are they talking about? I don't know. I don't
know. I mean, the main mandate, which was for
vaccination or testing if your business has more
than 100 employees. The Supreme Court stopped that
many, if not most, city mandates for required
vaccination to go places like restaurants, etc.
Those are being dropped. I don't actually know
what mandates they're protesting. But in any case,
Ted Cruz met with the trucker convoy,
and he claimed that flight attendants
and pilots regularly hug him. They
regularly hug him because he fights
the vaccine mandates. This almost certainly
didn't happen. This is a version of the sir
routine that Trump is known for. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: Every week I fly back and forth to
Houston, right? Almost without exception,
every time I know that I'm on an airplane,
either the captain or a flight attendant will
come up to me, will hug me and say Thank you
for fighting for us because I'll tell you United
Airlines. Sadly, Houston's ahead of them has fired
thousands of pilots and flight attendants.
Speaker 1: Now that's a lie. That's a lie.
United has about, I believe, 60000 U.S.
based employees and 200 people were let
go for not getting vaccinated. 200, not
thousands. Do the facts matter? Probably not.
Speaker 3: What difference does it make where
the District of Columbia right now that her
mandate is affecting kids in DC? This is wrong.
Speaker 1: OK, so this is a version of Trump's sir
routine. Trump, sir. Routine is when Trump goes,
you know, they came to me and they said, Sir,
Speaker 2: sir, sir,
Speaker 1: thank you
for doing this with a tear in their eye.
They came to me and said, Thank you, sir,
for allowing unvaccinated people to be all over
me and spread. It's almost always a lie when Trump
says they came to me and they said, Sir, it's
almost always a lie when Trump says, and nobody
really knows that it's almost always a lie when
Trump says, and it's really a shame we won this
election, but they stole it, and it's really a
shame those are triggers that it's probably a lie
with Ted Cruz. I mean, I think anytime Ted Cruz
is claiming others deliberately made physical
contact with with them, it's probably a lie. And
I can't imagine that flight attendants and pilots
are coming up to him and hugging him and saying,
Thank you, thank you for allowing and encouraging
unvaccinated people to be getting on our
airplanes. And often I'm guessing those are the
very same people that wear the mask under the chin
on the plane because they just don't know what the
Hell's going on or just don't care. But again, the
truth is United Airlines 96000 global employees,
about 60000 of those I think my numbers are right
are based in the United States. And of those,
60000 200 were let go for being unvaccinated
and for a very long period. I don't know if it's
still, but for a very long period of time. Once
United put in place their vaccine requirement.
They their employees stopped dying of
the virus. Now it's been so long now,
it's certainly conceivable that now some, some
vaccinated employee has died of the virus. It's
certainly possible, but for a very long stretch
of time, they were not. Give me a break. Ted Cruz
continuing to just tell these stories. And by the
way, why is he meeting with this trucker convoy?
What I would love to see Cruz ask instead of
ranting and raving in this kind of like faux
defiant tone about vaccines. I would
love to see him ask of the truckers
exactly which mandates are you here in
opposition to exactly which ones tell me?
Because there's barely any left and
all of the restrictions are falling by
the wayside? All right. So that's Ted Cruz,
and there are people who see him as a hero.
I don't. But there are people who do. We're going
to take a quick break and be back right after
this. Make sure you're following us on Facebook
at Facebook dot com slash David Pakman show.